we can go back to uh you know what mark
said in
2012 um when he was taking facebook
public
and you know this is the wake of the
arab spring i think people really have
to remember what an extraordinary year
2011 was it starts with the arab spring
um dictators are pulled down now people
say you know facebook took them down i
mean of course it was the citizens the
people themselves took down dictators
aided by
facebook and twitter and tell i don't
know
what or texting there were some other
platforms they used so
the argument that mark makes um in this
letter to
potential shareholders investors um is
you know we're at a turning point in
history
and you know with social media is
rewiring
we're giving people the tools to rewire
their institutions so this all sounds
great like this is the democratic dream
and what i write about in the essay is
the period of techno-democratic optimism
which began in the early 90s with the
fall of the of the iron curtain and the
soviet union and then the internet comes
in and you know people i mean people my
age remember how extraordinary it was
how much fun it was i mean the sense
that this was the dawning of a new age
and there was so much optimism and so
this optimism runs all the way from the
early 90s
all the way through 2011
with the arab spring and of course that
year ends with occupy wall street and
there were also
big protest movements in israel and
spain and in a lot of areas martin guri
talks about this
so there certainly was a case to be made
that
facebook in particular but all these
platforms these were god's gift
democracy
what dictator could possibly keep out
the internet what dictator could stand
up to people connected on these digital
media platforms so that's the strong
case that this is gonna be good for
democracy
and then we can see what happened in the
years after now first of all um so in
in mark's response to you so here let me
read from what he said when you
interviewed him
he says
uh i think it's worth grounding this
conversation in the actual research that
has been done on this which by and large
finds that social media is not a large
driver of polarization he says that then
he says
most academic studies that i've seen
actually show that social media use is
correlated with lower polarization
that's the factual claim that he makes
which is not true
but he asserts that um study well
actually wait it's tricky because he
says the studies he has seen
so i can't so it might be that studies
he has seen say that but if you go to
the google doc with chris bale you see
there's seven different questions that
can be addressed and on one of them
which is
filter bubbles the evidence is very
mixed and you might be right that
facebook overall doesn't contribute to
filter bubbles but on the other six the
evidence is pretty strongly on the yes
side it is a cause he also draws a line
between the united states versus the
rest of the world right and there's one
thing true about that which is that
polarization has been rising much faster
in the us than in any other major
country so he's right about that so
we're talking about an article by uh
matt matthew against cow um
uh and a few other researches a very
important article we've got it in the in
the political dysfunction um database
and we should say that in this study
there's um like i started to say there's
a lot of fascinating questions that are
it's organized by whether studies
indicate yes or no question one is does
social media make people more angry or
effectively polarized
question two is does social media create
echo chamber these are fascinating
really important questions question
three is the social media amplified
posts that are more emotional
inflammatory or false question four is
the social media increase the
probability of violence question five is
the social media enable foreign
governments to increase political
dysfunction in the us and other
democracies question six the social
media decrease trust
seven is the social media strengthen
populist movements and then there's
other uh sections as you mentioned yeah
that's right but if you once you once
you operationalize it as seven different
questions um you know like so one is
about polarization and there are
measures of that the degree to which
people say they hate the other side and
so in this study by uh by boxell against
cow and shapiro 2021
they looked at all the measures of
polarization they could find going back
to the 1970s for about 20 different
countries and they show plots you have
these nice plots with red lines showing
that in some countries it's going up
like the united states especially in
some countries it's going down and in
some countries it's pretty flat and so
marx says well you know if if
polarization's going up a lot in the us
but not in most other countries well
maybe facebook isn't responsible
but so much depends on how you
operationalize things are we interested
in the straight line regression line
going back to the 70s
and if so well then he's right in what
he says
but that's not the argument the argument
isn't that
you know it's been rising or falling
since the 70s the argument is it's been
rising and falling since 2012 or so and
for that now i just spoke with i just
i've been emailing with the authors of
the study and they say there's not
really enough data to do it
statistically reliably because there's
only a few observations after 2012. but
if you look at the graphs in their study
and they actually do provide as they
pointed out to me they do provide a
statistical test if you break the data
at the year 2000 so actually a
polarization is going up pretty widely
if you just look after 2000 which is
when the internet would be influential
and if you look just after 2012 you have
to just do it by eye but if you do it on
their graphs by eye you see that
actually a number of countries do see a
sudden sharp upturn not all not all by
any means but my point is mark asserts
he points to one study and he points to
this over and over again i have had two
conversations with him he pointed this
study both times
he asserts that this study shows that
polarization is up some places down
other places there's no association
but actually uh we have another section
in the google doc where we review all
the data on the decline of democracy and
the high point of democracy of course it
was rising in the 90s but if you look
around the world
by some measures it begins to drop in
the late 2000s around 20 2007 2008 by
others it's in the early to mid uh 2010s
the point is there is a by many measures
there's a drop in the quality and the
number of democracies on this planet
that began in the 2010s and so um yes
mark can point to one study
but if you look in the google doc there
are a lot of other studies that point
the other way and especially about
whether things are getting more
polarized or less more polarized not in
all countries but in a lot
you